en compagnie de pierre bonny ce bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le directeur général
de l'afnic alors là fixé l'association
française pour le nommage internet en
coopération vous est implantée à saint
quentin en yvelines et vous êtes
notamment gestionnaire historique du
point fr des sites internet
alors avant de revenir sur l'événement
le forum afnic pour un internet de
confiance que vous organisez du 2
juillet au 19 novembre
pouvez vous nous expliquer en quoi
consiste l'activité de gestion du point
fr bonjour à tous alors l'activité de
gestion du point fr ça consiste d'une
part à permettre l'enregistrement de
noms de domaine en point fr à travers
des bureaux d'enregistrement qui sont
des hébergeurs internet la plupart du
temps et puis ça permet aussi ça
consiste à faire fonctionner le point fr
c'est à dire à faire en sorte que quand
vous avez créé un site web qui
fonctionne en point fr les internautes
puissent y accéder
donc au fait on est à la fois une sorte
de notaire de l'internet ont dit à qui
appartient les noms de domaine et n'est
aussi un aiguilleur c'est à dire qu'on
permet de diriger tous les internautes
vers vos sites
c'est alors vous aussi vous avez un rôle
d'information de sensibilisation et
c'est dans ce cadre là que vous
organisez à partir du 2 juillet et
jusqu'au 19 novembre
un cycle de débats sous le nom du forum
afnic pour un internet de confiance et
les thématiques de ces débats c'est de
lutter contre les abus en ligne alors
pourquoi avoir choisi cette thématique
alors vous avez merci d'avoir rappelé
que l'afnic au delà de son rôle de
gestionnaire du point fr elle a aussi un
rôle historiquement en tant
qu'association d'habitation d'un certain
nombre de débats au sein de la
communauté internet française nous a
semblé que cette question des abus
étaient étaient traités de manière un
peu disparate
aujourd'hui faisait l'objet d'un certain
nombre de prises de position qui parfois
été techniquement assez mal informés
et une assemblée que justement ce
caractère un peu neutre du registre
internet.fr pouvait permettre de
rassembler un certain nombre de docteurs
pour faire le point sur ce qu'est un
abus comment on peut s'en prémunir et
quels sont les moyens techniques de
gérer les abus sachant que nous sommes à
l'afnic assez assez prudent sur le fait
que les abus sur internet que
techniquement
parfois ça se règle par d'autres
manières donc c'est une manière de faire
le point et aussi peut-être d'éclairer à
travers ce point là des décideurs qui
peuvent être des législateurs sur les
meilleurs moyens de limiter les abus et
les risques sur internet
alors pour nos téléspectateurs est-ce
que vous avez des exemples d'abus sur
internet alors les exemples les plus
courants ce sont des exemples qui sont
liées par exemple à des arnaques des ce
qu'on appelle le phishing c'est à dire
des d'aider des personnes mal
intentionnées qui se font passer pour un
site internet
ce qu'ils ne sont pas pour récupérer des
données des données cartes bancaires des
données personnelles des choses de ce
type là vous avez aussi des abus qui qui
relève de l'usurpation d'identité on se
fait passer à travers un email pour
quelqu'un d'autre pour commander des
choses à sa place c'est donc il ya
finalement toute une série d'abus
possibles
et puis il ya des abus qui sont des abus
qu on appelle des abus techniques par
exemple le spam
c'est un abus technique c'est à dire que
non seulement ça pose des problèmes à
ceux qui le reçoivent
mais ça pose aussi des problèmes aux
infrastructures de l'internet parce que
c'est énormément de messages qui partent
alors qu'ils ne sont pas légitimes
donc ça sera probablement un élément
dans les mois à venir qu'on aura
distinguer quels sont les abus classique
et les abus technique le premier sujet
que vous allez aborder ce jeudi 2
juillet 2
10h à 12h c'est une conférence en ligne
pour public pour tout le monde c'est le
traitement des abus dans le contexte de
la crise sanitaire que nous venons de
traverser
y at il des abus spécifique à cette
crise
alors ça sera l'objet du débat d'où je
ne veux pas à présenter ce que diront
nos invités puisqu'on ne sommes pas les
seuls à parler un bien sûr il y aura la
direction générale de la concurrence et
de la répression des fraudes il y aura
un homologues étrangers notre homologue
danois et il y aura un grand bureau
d'enregistrement qui est gandhi qui
s'exprimeront là dessus néanmoins nous
la vision qu'on a c'est que il n'y a pas
eu d'abus particulièrement spécifique
durant cette crise il ya eu les mêmes à
bulles d'habitude
simplement on était plus attentifs et
ont considéré que ces abus étaient
peut-être plus dangereux qu'il ne
l'était d'habitude c'est à dire que des
arnaques pour enfin des sites en ligne
qui vous envoie jamais votre votre
commande
malheureusement ça existe mais terne et
ça existe des sites en ligne qui vous
envoie jamais le gel hydroalcoolique
pendant la crise a beaucoup plus énervés
les jambes d'habitude
voilà donc qui a ri il ya eu une j'irai
une mobilisation contre les abus en
ligne qui a été plus forte en raison au
fond de deux ans sanitaire et du
confinement et du fait que beaucoup de
gens se sont reportés sur les achats en
ligne parce que précisément ils
pouvaient pas acheter
en vrai dans la rue dans les boutiques
donc pas de nouveaux abus mais une
sensibilité beaucoup plus forte aux abus
je dirais habituelle et pour en savoir
fait le plus du coût par rapport à cette
thématique
il faudra participer en tout cas en
ligne se connecter sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran c'est ce
jeudi 2 juillet de 10h à 12h merci
pierre bonny
merci beaucoup à vous directeur général
de l'afnic